superhero vibes are also strong with mr.
John Krasinski who's giving all of us
some much-needed positivity during this
pandemic yes welcome to prom class of
2020 despite having absolutely no idea
what I'm doing from DJ / actor turned
host John Krasinski's has been giving us
all some good news during the pandemic
but just how does he make it all happen
let's go
[Music]
Eilish is in the house I have my toy
Mike from my children I think it just
broke well getting Billy Eilish wasn't
difficult I heard you were an office fan
you've seen the show once or twice
twelve times and what about this guy we
should do a check on the weather Brad
how's it looking out there looks pretty
good Brad to take part in this show
let's be the Clooney connection John
started with Brad buddy George in
leather heads and we all know Brad likes
playing weatherman remember this from
2017 things are going to be getting
warmer in this area here and this area
here perfect John shoots all is under 20
minute feel good shows from the home he
and Emily share in Boston and check out
a set the I heart dad card and under
Mifflin mug and his matching Boston Red
Sox cap in boxer has two daughters
design the logo for his new gig as news
anchors it's the first time they know
their dad's job I think they pretty much
think I'm an accountant or something
when I say I'm going to work because
they're not sure what I do so I just
leave and then I come back that's all
they know remember no matter how hard
things get there is always good in the
world tonight
[Music]